[Musique]
non je vous donne un conseil si vous
passer des examens
ne traînez pas après derrière devant le
lycée a comparé les résultats ça ça vous
mènera sera il ya toujours des gars dans
l'île
[Musique]
non sur la deuxième en maths il fallait
en fait le résultat c'était 2x plus de x
y z aux caries ah ouais mais tu es sûr
que c'était pas aidé au cube
non c'est donc harry parce qu'à un
moment il ya deux aides qui fait nul et
là tu es en ra seras tu sais que toi tu
as mis 2 x + 2 y plus de z et tu rentres
chez toi et tu te dis je vais avoir de
ne parler à personne en
histoire-géographie combien de fois moi
j'arrive comme ça je suis tranquille qui
est la capitale de l'italie tobiko je
vis madrid je suis pas sûr c'est pas ça
va peut-être changer dans les prochaines
semaines mais l'a dit si les résultats
ça sera pas bon coin non voilà donc je
vous dis ne parler à personne
on est en race sera totale on rentre
chez soi on fait le vide et on passe à
une autre épreuve
on prend les matches les uns après les
autres je vous le dis c'est pas parce
qu'on a raté une épreuve qu'on va tout
les ratés c'est comme avec les femmes
c'est pas parce qu'on a raté un dossier
qu'on n'aura pas d'autres dossiers
derrière donc voilà donc on se bat on se
bat jusqu'à la fin des examens et on
l'aura cheval
[Applaudissements]
je
ouais
oh
[Musique]